foreign
[Music]
it's Saturday morning and we're on a
quiet residential street just a few
yards from the U.S Mexican border
we've had a tip-off there's been a
shooting in this flat above a
supermarket
I understand a woman's being killed here
but the police aren't too Keen to give
me information
all we know is the woman's body is still
in the apartment and the area is now an
active crime scene
[Music]
but we're in a city with one of the
highest murder rates in the world and
the shootings greeted with weary
resignation
the coroners here are busy always but
what she's found inside this time is
pretty horrifying
is the female 70 75 years whoa
do you think she will somehow as a drug
drug cartel yeah
this area yeah
even for Tawana the execution of a woman
in her 70s is a terrifying escalation
[Music]
city in Mexico today no women not
mothers not daughters not sisters not
even grandmothers are safe
from an epidemic of brutality that's
killing thousands of them a year
foreign
[Music]
on the outskirts of the city is the
largest Refugee Center in Mexico
which numbers of Mexicans are on the run
with
000 fleeing their homes over the past 15
years and the crisis is getting worse
every day
that is going to be our new shelter it's
a huge shelter in all the the families
are going to sleep in there how many
people
I think we're going to put 2 000 people
in there
the thing is the women and children here
aren't running away from some
cataclysmic natural disaster this is all
man-made
what is it they're running from
they are running because we have an
internal War all the characters are
killing the people from Michoacan from
Guerrero from Guanajuato and they're
running to be safe you are talking about
the characters and they're going to your
home they're going to kill woman their
small children
they're going to give everybody in your
house
all the women here have witnessed
suffered and somehow survived this
shocking brutality
Isabel is only in her twenties she fled
here from the south
and having seen what the cartel did to
her brother she's terrified
[Music]
see it
[Applause]
is
[Music]
the women are too traumatized to talk
openly about their experiences but
yasmin's determined that we hear her
story
she tells me how a drug cartel broke
into her family home kidnapped her and
held her to ransom for one very long
week
what happened during those seven days
when the authorities came looking for
them the consequences were horrific
ES
Uno
um
[Music]
thank you
Yasmin was beaten and tortured
repeatedly before she was finally
released by her captors
I'd heard of the cartel's reputation
almost Delight for savagery but this
young woman's story really brings home
the depths of their depravity
Yasmine and her children are now stuck
in limbo
like all the women here she's far too
scared to return home
[Music]
for them the refugee camps the final
stop on a journey they pray will deliver
them to safety
[Music]
and this is why the women flee to Tawana
its proximity to the United States
this is the world's busiest border
crossing
and every day hundreds of thousands of
Journeys are made between the two
countries
for those looking for salvation from the
violence in Mexico
crossing the border either legally or
illegally is their last hope
but that's becoming increasingly
difficult
[Music]
the lack of protection for women means
that record numbers are now looking to
escape the country and those trying to
help them are utterly swamped
Nicole's a human rights lawyer who
handles thousands of Visa applications a
year and her casework is a catalog of
atrocities we've worked with women that
have been burned have been mutilated
have been gang raped have been sold
we work with women that are so terrified
that they won't even leave the shelter
because they feel as soon as they step
outside those doors that they could die
and the violence inflicted on Yasmin is
not the only form of brutality many in
Mexico face
[Applause]
thousands of women in the refugee camps
are also fleeing extreme domestic abuse
crime that affects about one-third of
the female population here
women in many circles are not viewed as
persons of value are viewed as property
under the ownership of other persons
whether that's organized crime whether
that's their father or their spouse
women's lives don't matter women's lives
are not valued here
foreign
a world where your life has no value
every day she was terrorized by the
Narco gangs who ruled her neighborhood
and every night she suffered at the
hands of a partner who beat and
threatened to kill her
foreign
[Music]
it is
you're right Maria listening to that
you've got a very brave boy
foreign
talking to this family and the others in
the camp it's more and more evident how
extreme the violence is being meted out
to these women
but also how much it forms part of their
daily lives
one of the most striking things for me
there's a sort of acceptance that
something absolutely horrific is going
to happen to them sooner or later
there is such a level of violence
against women that not only do they feel
that it's inevitable something will
happen to them sometime
they're probably right
for tonight at least the camp offers
these women and their children a place
of sanctuary from a world that holds
often unimaginable terrors
and over the next few days as we spend
more and more time on the streets of
Tawana we begin to get more of a sense
of just how brutal that world is
excuse me
the Border City of Tawana is one of the
most violent in the world
[Music]
someone in there
it's a magnet for both Mexican and
international criminal gangs who battled
to control the multi-billion dollar
businesses of drugs and people
trafficking
in the first six months of this year
alone there have been more than 850
murders and the death toll for this
weekend reaches a staggering 20. we just
heard of another incident Apparently one
person might have been shot dead another
badly wounded
we're back in the city's Northern
quarter just a few meters from the
border
the woman who lives in the house where
the shootings took place tells me she
heard a noise outside well they were
really coming in the door and I was
walking to open it because it had a lock
on and as soon as I was gonna open it I
heard the gunshots
and well they were both in the floor
turns out the victims were Jennifer's
husband and her brother-in-law
and they were gunned down whilst her two
young children were in the house
told my oldest like don't look because I
couldn't even open the door they were
right there like they were in the way
like just don't look you know the little
girls uh yeah one is two and the other
one is ten oh my gosh
that's what I mean and
I don't know I mean I don't know what
the police are gonna do Jennifer is
almost numb with shock
in a few short seconds a seemingly
random act of violence has left her a
widow and her young family without a
father
well I have Mike I'm five months
pregnant
and why have my girls
so I don't know right now I really don't
know anything
devastating loss as a reminder that
murder statistics only ever count the
Dead
but the suffering of those who are left
behind impossible to measure
the overall responsibility for
protecting the citizens of Tawana lies
with the city's 41 year old mayor
if I put a microphone on you
Montserrat Caballero was the first woman
to hold this position
she was elected 18 months ago on a
promise she'd crack down on organized
crime
but with 20 murders in the last two days
alone I'm already getting the impression
she's facing an impossible task
big problem here is the guns this month
I got 150 guns of the street but what is
the problem the guns come all the time
every day
I mean that's crazy high numbers yeah
crazy it's crazy I got to this year one
thousand and three hundred to this year
just for this year
the city streets just aren't safe for a
woman who's received countless death
threats
but Montserrat insists is important to
be seen to be doing her mayoral duties
so for each public engagement she's
accompanied by a specialist team of
armed bodyguards who travel everywhere
in a convoy of bulletproof vehicles
this is the supposedly the most
dangerous song in the city in the corner
you get your head on in the most
dangerous part of the city exactly I
mean that makes sense
her job's No Ordinary job but then this
woman is no ordinary woman so her daily
routine includes a trip to the
hairdressers in the heart of the red
light district
and while these visits seem to make her
security detail nervous
the mayor is determined to show no part
of the city is off limits to her
there's something very cool about a
mayor who comes to the most dangerous
part of the city and gets ahead on
[Music]
salons popular with the female workers
of tawana's booming sex trade
many of them like Montserrat herself
have fled from the cartel violence of
southern Mexico
and it's this background that's made her
somewhat of a role model for a new
generation of politicians who are
determined to bring an end to the
Bloodshed in their country
your vision is a a future without really
heavily armed men having to patrol the
area yeah you get to a stage where it's
safe enough without them without them
you can walk and you can come with
because some people feel scared about
the soldiers but I hope someday we can
walk like without them
I imagine you can't do the job that
she's doing without actually hoping that
you can make a difference and try and
solve it so she's got to have that firm
belief like she said she's been driven
by her mother telling her all her life
you can do it you can do something so
she's starting out to tackle a massive
challenge believing that she can do it
can she do it well it's going to be very
very hard and I mean she's she herself
has got to be a target from some cartels
but it's not long before we Face yet
another reminder of the scale of the
problems she faces
traveling out of the city we run into a
group of demonstrators
[Music]
marches like these are a common sight
across the whole of Mexico
[Music]
these women are protesting that not
enough is being done to help them find
Los Desa persidos the missing ones
[Music]
both men and women have disappeared but
it's the female figures that are so
alarming they've increased threefold
just in the last six years
given the brutality of Mexico's Narco
Wars it's easy to guess their likely
fate
none of these women are giving up hope
so this one's from missing in America
Olga tells me about her daughter who's
been missing for just over three years
[Music]
the last she heard was that she was
stopped by a gang of armed men
behind every missing poster there's so
many questions but Olga's Hunt For
answers about her daughter is especially
poignant
and that evening we traveled to the
family home to find out more about the
girl who vanished Into Thin Air
is
and what was she like as a six-year-old
even though Selena's been missing for so
long her parents can't accept she may
never come home this is her bed
and you've kept all her clothing you've
kept everything
foreign
if you believe she's still alive
what's going through your head about
what she's going through if she's alive
onion
is
[Applause]
[Music]
thousands of families all over Mexico
regularly come together to hunt for the
missing ones
foreign
this is every parent's worst nightmare
but their determination never to give up
is inspirational
can we walk up with you
[Music]
today is Selena's parents have joined a
search Party In The High Ground
surrounding Tawana
these Hills are often used by the local
cartels to dump the bodies of their
victims
the family spent hours looking but it
feels hopeless mostly desperate
but late in the afternoon a call comes
over the radio of a possible lead
remains have been found abandoned in a
storm drain
[Music]
flurry of excitement
but they turn out to be the bones of a
small animal
it must be so disheartening for you when
you keep on getting moved
yourself
[Music]
foreign
disappointment
[Music]
at Olga and Alvaro and all the other
families will return
hoping that one day they may find the
answer to the most heartbreaking mystery
of their lives
[Music]
Mexico's Drug War means that while
Tawana is one of the world's most
violent cities
it's still a popular tourist Resort
thousands of visitors cross the border
every night
here they can stay in luxury hotels and
there are hundreds of bars and
nightclubs as well as an army of drug
dealers
and there's another multi-million dollar
industry that attracts tourists and
criminals alike
[Music]
the sex trade
prostitution is legal here
but some of the most notorious drug
cartels have now branched into human
trafficking
women are transported from all over the
country to Tawana for sexual
exploitation
either here or over the Border in the
United States
[Music]
this is where we would do our dances
you know hello
you wouldn't be able to stop you V used
to be a sex worker she started as a pole
dancer in one of the clubs in the red
light district and like many her
decision wasn't really a choice but made
out of economic desperation
when I first started working here was
because
um we were behind on rent it was like
I think 900 dollars that we were late on
rent it was a couple months past due I
had just had the baby
um and uh there really wasn't any other
alternative
within a short time we moved from
dancing to charging the men for sex kind
of loosen up with the customer get to
know them a little bit but yeah I'll
warm them up a bit tease them a little
bit and then once their 10 minutes are
up here you just go back and drink or
they get the courage to go upstairs
but with the extra money came extra risk
as her pimp savagely assaulted her she
didn't hand over her earnings
beating after being and it was it was
crazy and eventually like
that got to me he just attacked me you
know and he would just like hit me a bit
with his bare fist I think I got like a
really bad one right here but it was
like mainly all over my side so all of
this was like completely bruised all of
it
the fear of beatings left thee feeling
unable to escape
even when one of her co-workers was
savagely murdered
I saw the pictures I saw all the
pictures what did it show she had no
arms she had no legs
um you know and it was just
it was scary
trapped and terrified V became addicted
to drinking drugs
I just got lost you know you kind of
just lose a part of yourself
you know you lose a part of who you are
or lose a part of you know and you give
a little bit of yourself to every man
that you come across you know and have
sex with
with the help of a family friend we
eventually checked into rehab and broke
free from prostitution
an escape that she's convinced saved her
life
girls who are still now in the industry
my heart goes out to them I don't know
how they do it day in and day out you
know
not everyone has the same look that I do
you know
there's girls that die you know they
don't come back
foreign
[Music]
but there is one person determined to
protect the women on the streets of
Tijuana
I tried to make a message for the city
these girls if same like me and same
like you they are not different
earlier this year the authorities
started to investigate Adelita one of
tawana's biggest sex clubs
a joint operation was set up by the
mayor and the federal government to
monitor criminal activity in and around
the club
and in particular the use of underage
girls in prostitution
the problems I can have if they have a
children's word there
I go too close
it was a bold move that risked making
the mayor many powerful enemies
you must have upset a lot of people
what worried are you for your own safety
it's very dangerous but I don't feel
scared because when you take some you're
a reporter right you go to the war is
dangerous but you have a responsibility
so I have responsibility to do to
prevent and I have responsibility to
talk about about these people
the Mayors made it her mission to
Crusade against organized crime but
there's no escaping that she's taking on
some of the world's most ruthless
criminals and that makes her very
vulnerable and me very worried
[Music]
growing exploitation of underage girls
in the sex industry is deeply
distressing
I want to get a sense of just how many
of the most vulnerable are at risk
[Music]
this gives me an Insight a sanctuary for
the child victims of extreme physical
emotional and sexual abuse
or just one of them
it's run by Alma Tucker
who for the past 30 years has been
fighting against people trafficking and
the exploitation of miners
so tell me about this little things
history
we're so blessed to have this baby in
this house and her mom his mommy the
uncle star a first sexual assault in her
which says she was thin
to the point that he started bringing
men's to the house
to have sex with her
with us and she's relief then she's free
and also her baby is free
after all their early trauma Alma is
determined to give these young girls a
fresh start
but she knows it's going to take a long
time for them to fully heal
when the girls come to this home they
lost a lot of Hope
they don't trust us
they feel I'm here but when they're
going to take advantage of me
we're trying to encourage them values in
life
this picture represents those values the
respect love being strong and have faith
almost vacation is to give these girls a
safe haven but she has to be constantly
vigilant
many of these children's abusers still
look for them and she's terrified about
the increasing role of organized crime
in child sexual exploitation
don't stop me how big is it in Tijuana
I think it's big
what I'm hearing for uh
testimonies of other occurs then they're
being rescued
they're saying is a lot of girls it's a
lot of money in this industry why
because one drug you sell it once but a
human you can sell it 10 20 25 times a
day and the child oh yeah you can sell
yes hundreds of times hundreds of times
and it must make you rage inside
when just listening to you makes me rage
yes uh makes me very angry makes me very
I wish I'm I have more power to do more
things but it's
um I I cannot do more than I've been
doing it and I'm praying to God to give
me a strength to keep doing this
[Music]
if it wasn't for Elma the outside world
for these girls would be a truly living
hell
they're celebrating the chance to be
children again
and it's all down to another woman of
Tawana
with the guts determination and sheer
Humanity
to step up and fight for the rights of
the most vulnerable
I thought Alma was amazing
she's got an incredible aura and all the
girls responded to it she's like their
mother
the things that they noted about her was
that she was gentle she was kind she was
good
I'd want her as a best friend or a mate
Alma's house may well be a Haven of
happiness
but as we travel back into the city
we're again faced with reminders that in
this shockingly violent Society the
security and well-being of women
is something that can never be
guaranteed
[Music]
at the refugee camp the congregation has
gathered for a special service of
Thanksgiving
[Applause]
being called forward have been told
their time here is coming to an end
they include Maria whose son Ian stopped
his father from killing his mother
[Music]
[Applause]
Maria's been given an appointment with
the U.S immigration service
if she can persuade them that her life
is in danger she'll be allowed to join
her relatives over the Border in
California
[Music]
this is the moment that everyone here
dreams of the chance to escape to a new
life and a better world
foreign
the hills overlooking the city Selena's
father Alvaro is coming to the end of
his search
he and his friends have found nothing
but they receive a quest to move on to
another site
it's a few miles along the road down by
the ocean
and a young woman's reported her father
missing
the man's sister is amongst those who've
joined the search where do you think
they belong to
she recognized these years from his
brother but from her brother
her brother disappeared here
[Music]
the young woman's also identified some
clothes and they're her fathers yes
and now the outcome of the search is
looking increasingly bleak
a few minutes later everyone's worst
fears are confirmed when blood stains
are found in an abandoned outhouse
a forensic examiner gets to work
and the house is now officially a crime
scene
it's one of the dozens that has set up
all around the city every day in a cycle
of violence that shows no sign of ending
the cartels Revel in their reputation
for savagery here and it has a purpose
my name's Alex I'm a British journalist
I'm sorry to talk to you at this time it
means people are too scared to speak out
we're not here to get anyone into
trouble we're just here to help
no it's okay it's okay I'm just saying
to her if she wants to talk
it's really striking it's just how much
fear there is how terrified people are
of talking and and even speaking out
about
disappearances about killings about
kidnappings they're just so terrified
even the relatives who've got nothing to
do with it are worried that they'll be
hunted down and they too will end up
dead
this is the harsh reality in Mexico
today
as the violence increases so too does
the desire to escape and find a better
life
[Music]
migration figures are now at the highest
for 20 years
but the greater the numbers the greater
the backlash against those desperate to
flee
[Music]
I
what happened what happened oh what
happened voila
what happened
it's heartbreaking
12 hours ago Maria was convinced the
family was going to be safe from all
those threatening her now she'd been
thrown back on the streets by A system
that doesn't accept she suffered enough
do you think they've got the whole idea
of what's going on in Mexico wrong
if they if they think there's no war
here
hello
Las Casas
tell me what did you think when you
realized you're coming back
[Music]
the sight of a young family abandoned as
night falls in such a dangerous city is
a particularly haunting one they are the
image of just how far their country and
the world is failing them
[Music]
the truth is during my time here in
tawano I found very few reasons to be
optimistic they're virtually
non-existent
the exceptions have been the pastor who
runs the refugee camp
is the first school for the migrant
people in Tijuana
he works tirelessly to provide
accommodation to thousands of families
who'd otherwise be at the mercy of the
world's most brutal gangs
and then there's Elmer Tucker The
Fearless Crusader against sexual
exploitation
[Music]
who's rescued so many girls from the
darkest of places
and given them fresh hope
and finally there's the mayor and her
determination to carry on fighting do
you think you'll
you'll ever stop the violence against
women
yeah we can we can if we work together
she pushes on no matter how great the
risk to her personal safety from her
many enemies
a few days after we leave the city our
worst fears become all too real
municipality
the news breaks that the mayor's Convoy
has been ambushed
it's a carefully coordinated attack that
Bears all the Hallmarks of a cartel hit
squad
a report of the shooting reaches me
whilst we're covering the war in Ukraine
and as soon as we can we try to find out
what's happening in Tawana
[Music]
hi monster
we were very worried looking at what had
happened what did happen I was I was
with my bodyguard and when he goes and
in a way
somebody stopped him and and shot him
shorted him but monster you could you it
sounds like you had a very narrow Escape
I mean you could end up getting killed
I'm very lucky person they tried to
scare me and and I hope not nothing
happened to me or my family but I'm I'm
really work hard and I still
working hard that's pretty staggering
bravery why why is it so important to
you
I want to Freedom
freedom but we have a war with these
cartels we have a war and I want a free
freedom to my to my city to my country
[Music]
freedom from this violence for a nation
in the grip of such a brutal drugs or
seems a very distant hope
[Music]
now being deliberately directed against
the women of Mexico means they must no
longer remain invisible
and unless the world wakes up to the
full scale of the atrocities being
committed here
for millions of those most at risk is
too terrible to contemplate
[Music]
foreign